today NASA will announce the winner of a
student contest to name the next rover
to blast off to Mars among the nine
finalists on the list
endurance tenacity promise and courage
the rover is set to liftoff from Cape
Canaveral as early as this July and this
is a NASA animation of the two billion
dollar mission scientists hope it will
answer key questions about the red
planet's mysterious past for missions
from space agencies across the globe are
going to Mars over the summer and Mark
strassman does a lot of cool stories for
us went to Jet Propulsion Laboratory in
California where this new Rover was
built the last Rover to land on Mars
eight years ago was aptly named
curiosity confirmed still roaming Mars
today curiosity's findings piqued
scientists to dig deeper their belief
was confirmed eons ago our planetary
neighbor could have supported life
rewind three-and-a-half billion years
ago Mars we believe was much more
earth-like there was much more water
apparently we can tell that fairly
clearly from the geology on Mars there
was water flowing around rivers and
lakes and so forth
the big question is how earth-like was
it it's the question Ken Willeford team
will try to answer this is called the
spacecraft assemblies the deputy project
scientist for NASA's new Rover mission
our job like curiosity was this
environment habitable was there water
there how much what was its chemistry
then we'll go further and moe say it was
there life there there's a fundamental
difference between there could have been
life and there was life absolutely yeah
it's a big big jump there if Mars hides
evidence of past life will efforts team
hopes to find it preserved here in an
ancient River Delta at a place called
jezero crater the rover will drill into
rock to gather more than 20 samples that
may hold evidence of past microbial life
but to find out two more missions will
be needed to bring those samples back to
earth and that could take ten years
there's got to be a frustrating delayed
gratification with all this certainly
delayed gratification it's hard for
everybody
this latest Rover also carries some
gee-whiz gadgetry as engineer Mimi young
showed us you're getting an
extraordinary opportunity to see the
Mars helicopter it weighs just under
four pounds the first mini helicopter
set to fly on another planet it carries
two cameras at its flying range is more
than a half mile and if it sounds like
just another drone you try calculating
the interplanetary Aeronautics required
to fly in an atmosphere 100 times
thinner than Earth's which would be more
valuable the pictures that it takes are
proving that they can fly my very very
personal bias proving that it flies
because that's going to give us the
solid foundation to build our ultimate
dream which is just much larger aerial
vehicles in at Mars but to Ken Williford
most important is the prospect of
discovering ancient signs of life on
this now seemingly dead planet if you
find evidence of micro life of any kind
in Mars its distant past how much of a
game-changer would that be massive
implications in my view every human
being in the history of human beings has
had a thought something like what am I
doing here where did I come from you
know what's my place in the universe
questions now asked about Mars on the
only known planet with life for now for
CBS this morning
mark Strassmann Pasadena California and
the Rover will attempt to land on Mars
in febrile
of 2021 it will carry an experiment to
demonstrate a way to produce oxygen on
Mars which could be huge for future
travel there they want to find out if
there was life if there was I want to
know what happened to it yeah no kidding
everything jezero crater may hold the
secrets that can't wait to to see what
they find there may take a while I'm
still stuck on the name I like what
they've chosen so that finalists
tenacity and endurance I like both of
those I want to no one asked me but I
like I want to see whether that a
helicopter flies really cool stuff
you